Joey Boy have you read chapter 1043 if
not click off this video right now run
as fast as you can as far as you can and
never click on this video ever again if
you care about your life at all but if
you have welcome here's a quick
refresher in case you just got so hyped
up reading this that your brain kind of
short-circuited and you're wondering why
you have your keyboard imprinted on your
face the One Piece manga just dropped
maybe the most important panel of the
entire Series so far where we see Luffy
apparently starting to melt away
together with his straw hat with a big
fat the villain is about to get his ass
kicked hard type of grin on his face
with the text reading Nika a Japanese
sound for scheming laughter and of
course the name of the legendary Sun God
who most likely is the exact same being
as Joy boy
Joey Boy and while this clearly was a
real person during the void Century at
some point being Joy boy in my eyes at
least is much more of a title or status
that someone can acquire rather than
that same person being reincarnated it
has much more to do with inherited will
the D Heritage and potentially holding
the right devil fruit
[Music]
so what has happened here has Luffy
awakened his rubber fruit finally has he
awakened his true devil fruit power that
he never knew about or has he simply
been overtaken by Joy boy and yes I know
I know I usually don't talk about the
new chapters directly and I'm not in
favor of reading the scans so I'm really
sorry if I disappoint you with this
video but I got spoiled on it really
hard like all of it basically hard and
no way that I'm not gonna talk about
this now also even if you're judging
you're still here as well so let's just
go now I know that you have a lot of
thoughts and emotions about this because
so do I goddamn but before we hype this
into the sky for the most epic
transformation in one piece or stomp it
into the ground for Luffy getting the
same treatment as Naruto let's dissect
this one by one rationally calmly I'm
just gonna say that in my opinion it's
definitely the most epic transformation
ever in all of One Piece okay okay so
with the neutral grounds for this
discussion having been established what
do we actually know for a fact from this
chapter and what can we speculate has
and will happen actually when you really
think about it the only two things we
actually know for a fact from this
chapter is that Luffy is not that as
kaido has declared and something is
happening to his body that clearly
involves heat and even though it has not
explicitly been stated that Luffy is in
fact Joy boy I mean it would have been a
bit weird if zenisha were like Luffy is
Joy boy I mean it still has pretty much
been confirmed that that's the case Joey
Boy has returned so that's what we know
for a fact oh also fun fact zunisha in
the Japanese version says
joy boy is right there it's the same
phrase that Raja used for the one piece
and Oda actually put those little dots
behind the phrase emphasizing its
importance
now I'd like to stop large by pointing
out for the people who will undoubtedly
believe that Luffy has now been
possessed by Joy boy you might actually
be right about that I think there's
quite a reasonable chance that Luffy
legitimately died last chapter first of
all at least on the Japanese version
there is a sound effect where Luffy's
heart clearly starts beating again and
before that kaido actually declares
Luffy dead someone who clearly should be
able to tell the difference between
death and just being knocked out Momo
law and kit feel that Luffy's presence
has vanished and tried to Rally last
resistance the narrator declares that
kaido has won against Luffy and Luffy
himself has a grin on his face just like
Roger during his execution or himself
actually at loketown so there's actually
a quite legitimate chance that Luffy
actually had to die in order to awaken
his true powers or Joy boy or both I
guess I also think that Joy boy might
only be aware awakened in wano remember
how kaido was insistent that this
country was special how close it's
connected to the ancient Kingdom and how
it was closed off waiting for Joey Boy
to return
so quite possibly there is something
about wano that helps unlock these true
Powers which is why kaido who wanted to
become joyboy himself picked it as his
base of operations now one theory on
this that I've actually have had for a
while now is that the giant skull and
the sword on onigashima might have
belonged to the original Joy boy
together with the giant strawhead or
marijua I'm actually gonna make a video
on just that theory and The Ancient
Giants in general very soon so make sure
to subscribe if you want to see that and
get all the details for now though I
just want to point out that it might
very well be relevant if Luffy were
actually fighting and dying on top of
the first Joy boy himself with the fire
Festival being all about the spirits of
the Dead coming back to life at all
now we'll of course need more of kaido's
backstory for this but I think that just
like big mom it has been suggested
recently that at heart kaido also simply
is waiting for Joy boy to change this
cruel world it kind of sounded like he
was genuinely disappointed that Luffy
couldn't be Joy boy the first time he
knocked him out he even said good
because the more you laugh during his
fight with Luffy so who knows kaido
might have actually been the good guy I
guess here after all in a way all the
time trying to awaken Joy boy and Luffy
and this would actually fit nicely with
Odin telling him to get stronger for the
one who will come and open up wano okay
uh what's next I have so many notes
right here ah yes the old debate is it
bad writing if Luffy is Joey Boy no here
are just a few quotes about Luffy
throughout the story chapter 99 smoker
is all this purely a coincidence it's as
if the heavens themselves wanted to keep
this boy alive inherited will the
destiny of the age and the dreams of the
people as long as people continue to
pursue the meaning of freedom these
things will never cease to be gold Roger
chapter 100 perhaps they're the Pirates
we've been waiting for the captain has
quite a mysterious Aura around him what
do you think Roger crocus chapter 105
Marine Fort the man Roger has been
waiting for it's not you teach you may
eradicate their bloodline but their
flame Never Dies for many ages it has
been passed down through the generations
and someday bearing the weight of all
these Generations a man will appear to
challenge this world Luffy being special
and carrying the will of Joy boy has
basically been foreshadowed throughout
the story and so I really really really
don't think that it diminishes who Luffy
is and what he has achieved at all just
the opposite really when you think about
it he's the first one in a long line of
potential Joy boys including Roger and
probably Nolans that actually managed to
fulfill the criteria and awaken
it's a testament to Luffy's approach to
life his sense of freedom and his drive
to get stronger for the sake of others
that qualifies him for this title in
other words he has literally been Nika
slash Joy boy his entire life into the
entire story so far saving people from
Cruel Fates slavery and oppression and
spreading joy throughout the world
[Music]
not for nothing has Oda Sensei stated in
an interview before that this panel on
Sky Pia where Luffy looks exactly like
Nika is his favorite in the entire story
foreshadowing Joey Boy and showing what
Oda Sensei himself values the most about
Luffy his ability to bring people
together and bring them Joy I'd also
like to remind you that both the Sun and
laughter have been part of Luffy's
Journey since the start I guess the
Thousand Sunny Luffy's clothes in one
with his son on them his fire ability
and on top of that the sun has been
closely linked to the void Century
anyways we have the sun Pirates who
inspired by the sun god Nika use the sun
to hide the slave Mark of the celestial
dragons you have the sun and the flags
of alabaster wano and shandora and
everyone is waiting for the person who
can bring the dawn the Rising Sun now in
general I'm always impressed with all
the little details people tend to notice
on Twitter or Reddit that would
otherwise completely Pass Me By and I
want to give a special shout out to one
comment in particular on Reddit that
made the following fantastic observation
I sadly can't find the original anymore
and it's been reposted I think several
times since then but in case you're
watching this you're the real G here in
the chapter zunisha is talking about
hearing the drums of Liberation when
talking about the return of Joy boy and
will you look at that there is actually
a line in being sake that I've already
mentioned in multiple videos as the most
important source of information for the
void Century that goes like this waves
are dancing having fun it's time to
sound the drums if we let blow Winds of
fear then the end of us is near even so
tomorrow the sun will rise again we all
already knew that this song was special
talking about the Great War the kozuki
clan and the one piece and love tale
itself but now we actually have a clear
mention of joyboim or Nika in the song
as well Oda was really not joking when
he tried to tell us just how important
Juana would actually become now someone
else has pointed out there's actually a
book called The Sacred Drums of
Liberation that talks about the
struggles and resistance of people from
Africa who were pushed into slavery in
the 20th century and given that slavery
and racism is one of the biggest themes
in the entire story and sangotnika is
the deity who is supposed to give give
them joy and Liberation I find it very
very very unlikely that Ola Sensei was
not inspired by this book as well
there's of course also the by now famous
connection to the legendary Japanese
King joyo boyo who lived 900 years ago
in today's Indonesia joyo boyo was known
for prophesizing the downfall of his
kingdom by the hands of foreigners and
predicting a time period where it would
become glorious again that Kingdom also
left behind scriptures talking about a
great War very similar to the
poneoglyphs in one piece that by the way
were made by the kozuki clan bringing us
once again all the way back to wano now
the 1 billion Berry question is of
course what exactly is happening to
Luffy now that he seems to have awakened
Joy boy as I've discussed in the past
and we'll discuss in another video
coming next Wednesday wano has been
heavily foreshadowing something
happening with Luffy's devil and Luffy
of course still needs to defeat kaido so
the two options I see here are the one
Luffy will awaken his rubber fruit or
two he awakens his actual fruit the
legendary fruit whose real nature we
haven't seen yet that would of course be
a banger it would literally be the
biggest troll in the history of
Storytelling if Luffy had just been
using his fruit and Powers completely
wrong the entire time and still managed
to make it very powerful in the process
cute
Not only would I absolutely love that
because we will get an awesome new power
but also because it would prove Luffy's
genius by managing to maximize his power
despite only using a very small part of
his true abilities taking the hardest
possible way to the top but I mean who
knows maybe that's exactly the reason
that he could awaken joyboy in the first
place and I think that might also play a
role in how similar it looks to the
yummy yummy Nomi underlining that it's
the natural counter to Blackbeard's
ultimate devil fruit as well darkness
and the sun I also think that Luffy
being joyboy pretty much implies that
Momo is an ancient weapon like
shirahoshi one of the sovereigns that
the sea kings are waiting for today
now if you want to somehow survive the
break next week and take all of this to
the next level this isn't enough on its
own you have to know what options there
actually are for Luffy's Awakening
whatever this ability might be I would
be very sad if it weren't a mythical
Zone food honestly but there are also a
ton of really fantastic and awesome
options for a rubber fruit Awakening
that will absolutely change the game for
Luffy and that's why you really
shouldn't ignore this video because it
talks about all the possibilities that
Luffy might have for his Awakening